this guy posted the pictures of
[ __ ] getting draco tattooed on
their head
yeah that's all i'm saying because they
know they know the truth the real fans
where does that do you uh obviously you
have to follow that fan right
that's that got to get to follow like
because he sent me that okay after i
posted it was already another [ __ ] that
had got it on his arm
but the head the head is different level
of yeah that's like
that's a follower for sure
but then it's like when i told everybody
i just wanted to see who had the stink
team today it was 50 [ __ ] i'm
like damn
i got to follow all 50 of them did you
follow all 50.
draco in the face but the draco on the
face when you saw that
when you saw that tattoo were you like
impressed or scared because that's kind
of scary like some kanye [ __ ]
fans be hype beats like that that's some
insane clown posse [ __ ] if we're being
100 percent honest
yeah like when you see a fan get your
actual name tattooed on their [ __ ]
face
that can go like either way it could be
like yo i'm gonna have to block this
person because that's a little scary and
i don't
know that or yeah like how like when you
saw that had you like like how did you
feel that's crazy i mean that's just
like i ain't never seen that one before
that's one for the record the type of
[ __ ] who was drunk really on some draco
[ __ ]
and just like just just a weirdo like
that dude loves you
yeah yeah on some [ __ ] like weird does
he get free does he get free
hey does he get free merch like free
like hey look the show's
in your city we'll make sure you get in
all right
that should be his backstage pass for
the rest of his life